as the valley experiences a massive heat
wave this week officials are warning of
more potential fire dangers
arko mana joining us now live with a
look at what the major concerns are and
also what you can do to stay safe
orco well denise it's just after 11
o'clock at night but if we take the
temperature of this asphalt here
it shows that it is still more than 104
degrees
at this hour the extreme heat paired
with dry conditions is concerning
officials about everything from vehicle
fires
to brush fires up in the mountains just
throwing
a match outside a cigarette but
it's going to start a fire extreme heat
across the valley this week making fires
a potential problem
las vegas fire and rescues tim samanski
is concerned about vehicle fires because
of overheated wires
when it is as hot as outside as it is
that's generating the heat
there's nowhere for that heat to go
those wires could start melting
it might it might start a fire while
you're inside the house
if you notice an issue do not park
inside your garage also combustible in
these conditions
paint cans propane tanks and pool
chemicals we have them catch fire behind
houses because they're in direct
sunlight there's also concern about
man-made fires up in the mountains due
to a drier than normal fire
season these are levels that even in dry
years we have not
seen in several decades officials say
the recent sandy valley fire near mount
podesy was caused by target shooting
this time of year a spark normally takes
30 to 60 seconds to start a fire but
with our near record heat this week it's
much faster
if that spark lands in that same fuel
bed as dry as it is right now with those
high temperatures
that fire can start in two or three
seconds so bottom line
be cautious and to prevent fires and
protect yourself
stay indoors between the hottest hours
of the day
and sumanski tells me those hours are
roughly from between 2 p.m and 7
p.m another fire concern is with
lightning and officials say they're
keeping their eye on potential storm
systems
coming through town later this week
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now